this video is brought to you by Babel
and better help more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Terra ericon alongside these guys we're going to
let s 10 say your names I'm John You Know Me Maybe
I'm Aaron I'm I come here sometimes ah oh my gosh
you guys John has been with us actually from the
beginning behind the scenes edit down most all of
our saw reactions for me and Aaron the thumbnails
he's worked on it he's been in the juice in the
environment with us so he is here today to watch
10 we are so stoked for the final thing you guys
you better leave a like you better leave a comment
you better ring the bell ring the bell W that was
so good I love that also thanks prep for helping
us at down these videos also don't forget we call
you super sexy you get on the patreon you get sexy
and you can sne up with your own copy watch uh the
old sou with all three of us which will be awesome
also uh Greg and John offer exclusive highlights
and watch alongs over there on patreon so get over
there get sexy if you know what's good for you
speaking of Greg just real quick want to shout out
the man Greg we wanted to have him here we wanted
to do like a Quadra Force I'm heartbroken we both
love the sauce so just if you're watching this
just leave some Greg love down in the comments
cuz he's out there he's taking meetings and
making arrangements so that we all can be here
enjoying with you guys so give the man some love
love you guys I was scream crying in the corner
prying to hear that he is not going to join us
today but it's G to be all right we'll be okay
um also what else should I say uh we're just
we're sad it's going to end and hopefully
we get on another Series right yeah anybody
want to say any last things before we watch it
it's been great it let's play game let's play a
game I've been waiting for this same
I keep seeing it on AMC and I'm like
I want to see it but no I must be patient must
be John
fer got to get your sinuses aligned I did did not
like seeing him upside down I don't suppose you
can tell me how it looks can you unfortunately
I'm just the technician your doctor will have
your results tomorrow it looks great though don't
don't even trip you're very kind remember that
that tumor in your brain cancer has brought
grief and pain and fear into my every waking
moment today is a gift that's why they call it
the present bars bars big bars Sage wisdom Henry
Kesler stage four pancreatic terminal that's
what they tell me anyway but I'm going to fight
this to the end all right another support group
it's an Easter egg you guys how much time do I
have months at best I still have a lot of work
that needs to be done my advice retire that's
my friend David Alano was in Saw 10 crazy
so you actually know that guy finally did
you warn him what's going to happen to him if
he doesn't take good care of John I haven't so
your advice to me is to die easy you're the
first one trapped bad advice it's crazy how
this man has been doing Saw movies for 20 years
and his not age today they keep him looks the
same oh no man what are you doing bro for real
oh my God like also aren't there cameras
also you suck someone's going to notice
this at some point really wow oh my God
God dang it's interesting now to see like
healing devices looking like torture
oh God no oh no we're already here oh
jeez ha karma [__] Karma baby exactly got the
inspiration right from the the patient damn I'd
like to play a game yeah yeah baby you said the
thing I've had my eyes on you and I do not like
what I see your job as a custodian is a noble
one sanitizing and sterilizing the hospital oh
my God helping patients avoid sickness but
there is a sickness inside you that needs
to be excised you have the ability to not only
save your soul today but your sight exed click
the dial across the five positions and you
will live to see another day oh Christ you
have 60 seconds he ain't going to make it
bro you would have turned that dial oh my
God no oh my God is this just a shot back
it's going to suck it out oh my God oh you
knew this was coming Pete oh my god oh oh
oh yeah the hot head shot oh I can't I I
can't God thank you so creative
[Music] God Jesus I hate
this no no no this is so awful oh my God you're
[__] Jesus oh my goodness only
one eye oh the other one nope
nope my my
gosh that was insane please tell me that that was
a Flash Forward and not just a fanty and not just
to like maybe I'll do this a he's just a fantasy
damn oh wow that was a good choice very inventive
live or die I'll I'll take it it was still a
good trap I'll take wow that was a great trap
and it's a good window into John's mind I love
that he saw the the traction on the fingers it
informs the Trap itself like good [__] so good
thank you just a little French press coffee he a
sophisticated man John CR man of class that
coffee was in his last will in tes Henry we
were in the same cancer support group John Kramer
this guy's familiar too You Look Marvelous I feel
great correct me if I'm wrong but you were
yeah stage four pancreatic but now 4 months
later I'm in complete remission what wa that's
insane how it's a long story i' love to hear
it you got a minute to tell me horse steroids
he just drank a lot of green tea I read about
a doctor he went to Nicaragua Finn Peterson he
offered a treatment it is a groundbreaking drug
cocktail combined with surgery oh interesting
coffee first then torture who it's my war wound
it looks bad but it was totally worth it
is it available here the treatment's not
available in the states the uh the medication
isn't approved by the FDA it's usually how
it goes put the whole FDA in a trap yeah I um
haven't seen them since my treatment in Norway
but John just go to carage I know there's
some people out there treat you nice oh
my God we're not Savages jigsaw strange
I'm here for it traps with magic oh my
God it's still good good luck man I'm rooting for
you oh boy they did a good job at really looking
him making him look sick this time yeah and he
looks really sad too like I really feel what he's
going through right now yeah I like that we're
living living in in his shoes like finally kind
of for once in a more human way under the right
circumstances and with the proper stimuli jeans
can be turned on and turned off like a light
switch is this like crisper guys know crisper
everyone loves crisper what we managed to do is
to create a new cuttingedge drug cocktail along
with surgery to teach the malignant cells switch
off wonder how much medical research they did on
this my father Dr Finn Peterson was forced
into hiding by corrupt governments and their
relationship to Big farmer put him in a trap
because my father was on the cusp of curing
dozens of diseases can you imagine what that
implies well the big drug company certainly
can I'm taking his treatment on the road for more
trials to save as many lives as humanly possible
road show let's do this next up John Kramer sorry
I'm just I'm just imagining Cartage traps now
your limbs the sling ring will close around
your neck severing your head in a different
Universe we received the email with your medical
records so I'm calling you now because we have
spots opening for treatment in about 3 months
too long too late I got a bunch of conflicting
traps around then you don't have 3 months
do you but we have a team of Specialists
here gathered a group of eligible patients
to start treatment a week from now I think
I could add one more spot could you tell me a
little more about the treatment oh boy it's a
two-prong treatment that uses my father's seop
phenol cocktail and in your case it would be
combined with a cranial surgery to clear the
tumor we've been there but I want you to know
that we found a very beautiful locasion for
our Clinic outside Mexico City oh good glad
it's pretty what date did you have in mind oh he's
like he's getting choked up the fifth Friday After
Next I think I could make that he might live
to see another day maybe he'll make it this
time trap making yes maybe this is a different
Universe yeah it's going to set up a whole new
timeline oh dang saw on the road
soxo Baka take a look at that that's
a metropolitan Cathedral nice that's a
cool shot yeah that's the olastic stat of FL
that's where the priest Cho the heart out of
their subjects and roll in them the huh damn new
game awaits yes I think they originally wanted to
shoot this this stuff set this in Prague and
then they had to switch to Mexico at a later
point or something okay but I love the vibe
I like seeing International saw yeah yeah me
too hey gay you okay [__] no thank you it's a
trap pigs come out the ma get out Jesus what the
what's your name John Kramer Li to me again and
I this chamber in your ey I'm not lying my name
is Johan Kramer not to worry s krer you're fine
you're safe what what what what the hell that's
even more disconcerting right depending on how we
feel this is either a kidnap van or a rescue van
huh your room here probably because the doctor
had to go into hiding so they have to like throw
people off the scent I guess and they must have
arranged the taxi and he must have known where
he was going I am John Kramer come hi gabri
this movie takes its time and I like it yeah
yeah like there's and it's like still I feel
it like guess it's good he me fromia like even
though they're taking their time it doesn't feel
slow Dr Cecilia Peterson she save life my life I
get I get now yeah this is fascinating cuz this is
the first time I've ever like oh hope he makes it
you know they really putting him as the the lead
of this whole thing really interesting Mr Kramer
welcome oh oh dude but we've had to beef
up the security wherever we go the big
drug companies are always one step behind we
must keep our location secret from everyone
even you which is no small feat I tell
you and they're good at selling you the
hope of like I I know this is all going
to go bad but like I'm hopeful at the
moment living in his hope which is smart
our local football star his father is a
caretaker I'm hopeful for John but I have a bad
feeling about everyone else here not that not
that they're bad not suspicious but something
bad's going to happen okay maybe the people try
to the pharmacy people come and then John sets
up a bunch of Pharmacy traps and kills them all
yes take all these pills yeah takes Revenge
traps exactly yeah people love SAU six you
know whoa so Advanced mattio is an
anesthesiologist at hospital alge he
did his residency at Johns Hopkins has
worked a lot with my father damn love
me some anesthesia this is Valentina one of
our nurses she'll be taking some scans and
drawing some blood all in preparation
for the injection therapy later today
excellent he's clear for release wonderful
excellent P John Kramer that was [Laughter]
Corney don't be coughing near me bro
C me up from yesterday oh took out
a tumor the size of my knob oh
wow they're a type of cytotoxic
lymphocytes I've been a civil engineer
and an architect most of my life and a
dungeon master now I have a few Hobbies
I I re rehabilitate the wicked I help
people overcome inner obstacles classic
car inovation sometimes involving a car
make positive changes in their lives like
a a life coach yeah or life dying a life
doua
a you speak English Carlos okay that's
about as good as my Spanish how do you
say pull pull pull pull Hala H Duo
jigsaw or today's video sponsor Babel
okay voila aw and who performs the surgery
Dr Ramon Cortez he's the best neurosurgeon
in 2000 miles he's the Dr IU if my own family
was on the table now we'll be performing an
awake craniotomy excellent oh that's fine
he was alive when they drilled into his
brain or awake awake I said alive I meant
awake when they eventually drill into his
brain he will be awake in the future
and his brain get drilled into right
the did he's like been there
done that saying [__] that's
why he was so chill in Saw Three is
because of this it all makes sense
now and then they shave his head and give
him the little soul patch he comes out
of surgery with the soul patch and that's
all they [Laughter] did why God nice it's
almost like the Exorcist in the like the
actual medical procedur is part of what's
actually scary and c and harsh yeah I'm
sure the torture here will be gross and
disgusting but also but this is pretty
yeah this is pretty still like cold and
yeah it's wild he's just watching them like
play around in his brain no no don't turn it
away don't you don't need to see this it's going
to get pretty crazy on this end of things we're
going to put you back to sleep I'm going to
come down from 10 thought you supposed to be
awake yeah what happened here what is this hi
there you did great that'll be$ 144 million
we're two blocks away from aa's hospital in
case you need a transfusion got your blood
work it all looks good John damn now you can
make 10 more of these mov drink two a day one
in the morning and one at night in addition to my
father's treatment it contains a painkiller you'll
need for the next seven days seven days after
that what happens then your whole life happens
then I never thought I'd feel this much
for John I'll we the second half of the
payment tomorrow morning thank you
John that's what you want to hear
this is the uest beatest Saw movie yet yeah
how about two more movies in the continuity
John oh buddy Cinema well and the tones
here are like way warmer way more like
orange yeah than the typical blue green cold you
know damn for him being a million years old like
why do you have abs right now bro hey man he's
an engineer he's always lifting parts and moving
things get out of here he's got Bobby Hill and a
head trap Dam yeah John we saw what you've been
doing he feels rejuvenated oh he don't give up
his oh he doesn't like that one why not is he
going to give up his work now [Music] takila
just want to hear that whenever I open some
tequila you have a gift card it's for a
friend a a Ros John you're so [Music]
sweet I love that they gave him this movie
yeah right it's kind of funny cuz the last
movie barely had any traps and I was
like this is boring but this is like
so engaging this is great I love this I
love it well they know I mean just like he
is he is the best most unifying part of the
franchise yeah the most interesting by far
hey Spanish getting better he's all
learning bar Mo [Laughter] Malo see less M
than mine oh bad things Badness Badness and
Badness that happened to all of them and now
he's going to go teach him a lesson s Revenge
s Revenge where is everybody this looks like a
perfect Warehouse to do some killing to play some
games oh they just got out of Dodge yikes the FDA
got him it's okay guys they move around a lot this
is totally innocuous everything is fine it's took
it on the road surgeons of Tomorrow what is oh
Jesus oh God they were watching a video or wait on
how to I am this is where he gets the inspiration
for a bunch of videotaped hello welcome to section
five in our neurosurgery series human brain is a
mystery hundreds ofli oh yeah yep yep yep yep
this means that you'll be floing in music oh
my god oh oh take a good close look you got any
scarring back there or anything oh God ooh oh
no damn they didn't do thing they didn't
do anything at all wow could fly all right
oo those edits damn why did the guy with
the pancreatic thing have a scar oh God I
am I'm wrecked right now maybe they were just
like well it's on the back of this guy's head
there's no way he'll be able to check right
wow that's so sick thank you man have a good
one course than we didn't see them see him
give them money but yeah he just transferred
it digital well there's they definitely
got that money of course they did yeah man
[__] hey baby game is on
Revenge Revenge R Revenge
Revenge yeah buddy my
god oh you oh my God oh my
God I've told you what you
wanted to know I've told you who you're looking
for no that ain't going to work
though oh man yep now the game
begin let me give you the illusion
of Hope like you gave me yeah
yes let's go hello Diego or should I call you
Dr Cortez wow I'd like to play a game attached
to your arms are two explosive devices yeah
buddy sort of cancer a malignancy that must
be cut out for you to survive the blades
cannot cut through the galvanized cable
but they can and slic through flesh and
muscle allowing you to cut the cancer
away Jesus let's go and then just slide
it off your bones right let's get some de
gloving you're screwed buddy God
just to have him right there yeah
that nod oh go ahead get on with it
this the first time we've SE seen
him actively watching in front of them
and they know that what's what's going
on except for jigs offw but like that
movie doesn't count oh god oh yeah
no why does it take so long just do it that I hate
it golly the cancer my [Music] goodness
now move those effects are gnarly dude
oh my God I want it oh my [Music] God it's
exactly the experience I was hoping for oh
God come on Dr cabby God look at that come on
buddy you got it right yeah oh you were running
long time come on buddy speed it up cuz I
can't handle much more come on now you're
done dude you're done wow dude to bite it out
oh my God oh my God kick it away kick it away
well done man all right oh wow you won you did
it he did he's like very good yes okay okayy
someone wins okay wow it's been a Min it's
been a Min since a win yeah man what happens
now detective I could use your assistance in
locating some people that are in need of our
surfaces oh all right love that he approached
him there with the like you survived compassion
yeah yeah I wonder if he's going to be helping
out for this or if he's just going to go rest it
off is she the other doctor yeah Valentin was the
nurse
damn okay damn oh my God you both about to get
jigsawed for completely different
reasons [Music] yeah oh oh yep nice
behind
you and the
graffiti guy are we going to do a
multi-person trap we must right everyone
involved God she was prostitutes
and junkies for this whole
operation no oh no hey no he just gave him
mistak right yeah each one of these dogs is
a good boy they're never going to be in a trap
all right they won't be ever they appreciate
life don't tase me
bro you had to go all this way
just to take your pills is that
secretive oh I can't wait for a pig
mask to come over up the top or the
[Music]
bottom look
up oh damn well done [Music] oh my God
Jesus oh my God John wow well yeah next
week Margaret oh my God he didn't even pay
scheduled already but I think that we might
have room for one more spot oh please no no
need to cry Margaret I'm not an angel it's
pure science J oh you going to die horribly
in a really rough way honey awful ways this
is such an interesting twist I love it John
is the protagonist of this movie what dude
that's crazy well and she is a terrific
antagonist because she is so you know
kind of warm and and seem so believable and
trustworthy and Earnest and then she's just a
raging giving people their worst times yeah yeah
look at your beautiful house all filled with li
money hope he's just standing there in the
field yeah right or the pig the pig masks
yeah you can see me it doesn't matter I'm
going to get you anyway nice love that love
that this a well chosen location house very
different setup from all the other ones cuz
like I don't even see a scenario where there
would be the traditional saw twist you know
it's not that kind of film these surveillances
are taking place during the events of saw one
actually oh you can see yourself
there he is there he is oh
boy oh yeah oh here we go amazing it doesn't
matter where you stand [Laughter] yeah he just
threw the rock don't defraud people and
glass houses now the question is there
it's going to be the mask is it going to be
the mask is is John working alone or did he
calling some help for some friends it's
a good question I don't know that's a j
that we got that's that's got to be John
yeah there he is who's this who's this
onea oh my God hi girl oh we can't get back
together who are you this is my associate
Amanda oh man shie Smith back in
Action yep is Hoffman here too
get some rest Cecilia you're going
to need it you're going to need it
yeah you are oh [__] you crazy ass oh
my God love it oh yeah oh yeah here we
go here we go this whole movie set in
Mexico that's wild my God why was back
here oh this is going to
be gnarly it's going to be
lit man speak of the devil oh we're only trying
to help you that game is over and a new game
is about to begin yep please listen to me I beg
you I beg you we had nothing to do with this we
didn't know what was going on it was all her M I
don't even know if that's your real name it is my
real name it is oh I meant no harm I would really
like to believe you you'll have a chance to prove
yourself
a oh the key to your freedom is inside inside
that box it's a Jil saw I thought you said there
was a key he was speaking metaphorically when
I get out of here I'm going to kill both of you
mother oh dang girl that is not the time don't
say that you're going to want to really listen
carefully to the rules in order to pull that
[Music] off the wire saw inside that box was
invented by an Italian physician Leonardo jile
it creates an extraordinarily clean cut to the
[Music]
Bone yeah oh my God ow ow the daughter line on
your leg marks the spot are you Cy the wire soil
that's wrapped around your neck will first cut
into your skin then your vertebral ligaments and
finally it'll sever your spinal cord I got all the
diagrams from from your fake ass doctor office you
won't you wouldn't oh oh you don't know who you
messing with lady we won't but Valentina might all
of you oh you promise dying people dying people
mhm yep get them you took advantage of the only
thing that they still possessed who no John we've
worked to heal people John Kramer going to make me
cry right now my associate Amanda here has had
to look at your bank records who would lose 34
people to you did you heal any of those 34 people
yeah I want to know you've been doing this larous
dance now for more than 8 years wow that's more
than $8 million wow we know everything we have
everything including the cash from your house
please help me please this is not retribution
it's a Reawakening bars there are more than 5 lb
of marrow in the human body all you need is 3 o
just suction it out it'll be transferred to that
device and it'll deactivate the saw around your
neck don't hesitate cuz your time is prescribed
Choice words boy nice you'll make it so long as
you keep your head I love Amanda I love their
Dynamic with each other this is not right not
right the lecture in moral decency yeah how is
she not just been like I'm so sorry take all my
money let us go this was a mistake I'll never
do it again yet she's just like this was wrong
even if she did do that get it but I might still
at least like apologize for being scr a raging
te what do we do this set I really like
it's like old school and that this shot
is it's cool yeah where this that like
a factory gu what you mean though the
setting is like really tangible it feels
like different feels like we're somewhere
else but it's still like real grimy real
something JN could get his hands on you
yeah oh God the t t put it on God damn it
Valena T it on come on girl oh my God stop
panicking oh my God yep yep y y on yeah
use some of those fake medical skills
you got this it your leg how tight is that
tourniquet not very tight no not tight at all
[Applause] boy I can't oh girl you
running out of time stop don't think just
jeez each time oh boy oh my God this is awful
ow ow ow ow ow no no oh oh boy no there the
sound a good workout bro you got to have like
oh you a full minute left you got time wa oh
my God she got her [__] leg off dude well
done well done that'se oh girl you did it get
that b marrow out baby you got another job to do
now you're running out of time oh girl you about
to bleed out let's do this sucking it out of the
stump oh my God this is insane wouldn't you pass
out before you cut your leg off that's what I'm
saying probably maybe no there's no shock in this
universe this is so nasty oh my God my God
still no are you are you are you in a bone
are you getting actual marrow here you
getting marrow because it doesn't look
like you oh no there there's oh my God no no
after all this no no no no no oh come on oh my
god oh Jesus Christ make it BR so hard me to
she going make it she ain't going to make it
[Music]
[Music] no and there she blows oh man nice jeez
wow wow oh bummer off off off with bummer you
brought me into this you brought me into this
get it you get it Gabby I'm not the one addicted
to oxy am I uh-oh they're turning on each [Music]
other this is between two and three right I think
this is between one and two if I'm not mistaken
yeah I'm not sure I think I think that's what it
is I heard a lot people say 1.5 when talking
about this do you want to keep going yes the
pain just comes in waves oh oh man I'm not ready
to do this without you you are ready and you can
you even want to do it without him and eventually
you will sa into his head right now a man of these
people deserve to be tested that lady doctor
deserves nothing everyone deserves a chance
you should know that more than anyone yeah buddy
the lighting right now I love it they make him
look like John is very Angelic almost Godlike
with the choosing of the light in this along
with his like metaphorical pull of teaching
them a lesson what oh here we go what are you
doing no wait what no you can see you guys wait
why is she she saw the first movie there's a key
hidden in there like how does she she clearly
knew this would happen and she prepared for
this we have a rope what you're
crazy bro you're insane give it
up give it hell no Jesus Christ oh okay
just got to pretend it is an actual rope
and not it and it's not going to slip right
through our fingers it's just a bloody rope
this is not s dude oh they want the
phone okay okay yeah they want that
phone this is incredible never in a million
years I think I've seen this in a movie
that's great that's great looking like the
queen of Hell over here h a MAG kidna by
a buddy now sit you been waiting to do that
haven't you you're right I'm a total fraud
but my Father John is real teal and you
know that he can save you is that your
concern H I swear to God that's who I
was trying to call I was trying to call
God they got a good Ensemble for this too
like I like the other ensembles and stuff
but they're way more grounded in this
yeah everyone everyone is very good yeah
oh this guy yeah I've come to get my money
back and I'm not going hey you oh my nice so he
called o Nice Shot I was going to say
I guess we needed one cop in this movie
even if he's still a victim of [Music] something
oh just a prop okay okay smart to test what he
[Music] do
D oh right girl now you got to test
him too variable interesting I know
you Kramer brain cancer right
solidarity among the struggling
in this movie what are you doing
here Parker I came to get my money
back h oh my God enjoy the show join us they were
all con artists and we we were the suckers yeah
they gave for everything all the money I had
that was for my family that money well don't
worry you're going to get it back what's your
life really mean to you Parker have you ever
thought about that because if you find the meaning
of your life what you found is your soul yeah damn
philosophical John was trying to give Mr SE as
a a chance to make his choice I'm going to give
you an opportunity to do something significant
with your life okay can you please talk to me
please talk to me you [__] you my God not that
those are yeah jeez Taste of the face wow taser
face taser [Applause] face everyone's laughing
at you he's a monster he's going to kill you the
same way he's going to kill all of us you don't
know John if you want any more of my help keep
your mouth shut about that dang Amanda's helping
you girl oh she wants you to win shoot she sees
kinship is that how I don't shoot that thief in
the face trust me Mr Sears in
short order she wish that you
had wow front row my man God hello they've pulled
me in so far I keep like I forgot about it yeah
forgetting to think about these things oh oh
oh my that's was on the what he was drawing on
the paper that he [Music] tossed oh she oh God
that's creepy what are we doing Billy oh my man
oh wow oh what a good shot that's great Amanda
prepare the puppet yeah I'm like did he bring
all his jigsaw saw gear just in case or did he
have it like shipped out here no when he told
her to come she brought all the stuff that's
right of course of course course makes perfect
sense oh the
camera yeah at least we bother to shave a
patch that just play me I'm not going to touch
something whoa whoa whoa you must oo
touch that thing now the meat AR e
e place a big enough piece of your cerebral
tissue into the glass enzyme tank and you win
a piece of what gray matter piece of your
brain remember how you reenacted the video
buddy come on now if you complete your
task in less than 3 minutes the enzymes
will dissolve the tissue to close a circuit
this will save your life jeez the brain is a
remarkably resilient T organ have their brain
removed only to have it rewire itself so that
the patient not only survives but thrives
wa the only thing I have not provided is
your anesthetic but trust me you will want
to remain alert yeah is there a c is this
is yes oh my God okay I don't I don't like
those sound that sound makes my teeth hurt
y'all Jesus Christ ow no thank you oh God ow ow
ow dude who thinks of these things this is wild
John Kramer oh oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God yeah buddy you got it you're doing
good you're doing so good you're doing great
you're doing so great yeah kill I like the way
they've sort of updated the ghosts freak out
effect that was the very first old school cut
technique that we've seen in this movie at least
since the eyeballs yeah yeah oh right eyeballs
oh yeah my God yeah W oh my god
dude oh yep get a spoon get a
spatula get Spork out come on
start scooping start scooping I just
have to pretend just pretend it's a
juicy soup it's a soup it's fake it's a
movie it's fake I hate it I hate it oh
my oh my goodness wiggle wiggle wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle wiggle go
oh my god dude I love there are chemical
reactions involved in this and and H more
brain more brain get more brain more
brain yeah just start getting handfuls
man you're done son you're done oh
what are we oh my God whoa I like
the azte yeah is it going to send his
heart rolling down the stairs oh my God
it's going to rip out his heart right maybe
not fry and Maiden wow oh my God I'm dying
you have to face that but our work's not
going to hit and I'm trust trusting you
a carry on these twoo how can I movie be so
up and have so much heart at the same time I
know oh wow I love these two being with
this franchise for so long like this is
beautiful I want you to go and free
Mr Sears and see if he'll play by the
rules that's Billy St God God
nope nope nope you have to take
it no we'll never get out of here
otherwise you have seen what's been
happening
uh hello Gabriella I want to
play a game no no stop it stop it
oh
whoa oh oh no oh H upside down oh okay
oh yep you're going to play now girl oh
oh oh oh halfway to drone and quartered is
sort of reminiscent of Jigsaw remember when
they uh they had to hang and he like oh
no dude you got to play the rest of the
tape girl oh [Music] jeez waa what this is
going to spray tequila at you drink as much
as possible although you all pretended
to cure my cancer I have spent years in
treatment chemotherapy immunotherapy radiation
whoa radiation machines are not to be trifled
with oh my the only way out is to free your
hand and Ankle use the tool above you flesh
can be grafted it will not be easy but
then nothing worth having like life is
that a was going to try to help her there's
nothing do she got it delayed only so long
I guess this one doesn't need a clock
we have to break your hand and Ankle oh
yeah I guess to fit it through right oh
God no no no no no stop with your foot
you'll swing out of the way don't Drop It
For The Love Christ oh shouts out to Eric
matthewsa
ow ow ow ow ow oh my God oh my God oh my God oh
boy oh my God it's already burning that's intense
Oh my Jesus goodness what a crazy it worked oh
[Music] jeez waa girl you you definitely got
skin cancer now something yeah you knew it you
knew it of course you knew hey hey no that was a
great reaction so exhausted come on It come on we
go oh God she's dangling so high though yeah she
going die from the fall but she's going to hurt
herself for sure I don't think she'll yeah right
I think she'll be okay um maybe just a broken leg
ow ow [Music] ow okay the fall wasn't that bad it
wasn't too high I guess as far as games go that
wasn't like the worst they gave her semblance
of a chance okay play time's over of course man
why buddy the keys to Cecilia chains you don't
need the keys she's not going anywhere also you
came in ready to kill her what the what the f man
did she unload the gun F like she unloaded
it it's an interesting thread to
include thought you forgot about me not a chance
oh no he was a plant a sucks he was a plan all
along I should have called that out the second he
showed up and he was in the the room already I was
like do they have a fake patient here just to sell
it come on Old Man lock yourself in oh [Music]
no this was part of the plan a cage is going
to form around him he'll descend into the floor
safe we need to get her to a hospital she won
her game and she deserves to live her injuries
need medical treatment do they you wouldn't know
anything about that though are you the killer dude
really oh my God you're the worst no no no no no
no no no no wow what you just spent all that time
helping her oh what a snake why would you do that
what a true snake you're going to have to get the
money back from me before you two can split her
it's upstairs you know she's eventually going to
kill you too right Amanda don't talk to Amanda
that way when I realized who you really were s
and now the great John Kramer is going to die in
one of his own traps there's some Wicked irony
sure what is this insurance who we got who
we got who be oh who is it is it your boy
oh oh no it's the boy soccer player get in here
kid the kid who helped you know this ho is dead
in 2 months but I want him to suffer I want his
last memory to be watching someone innocent die
you've learned [__] from your time here hey
Carlos hi how you doing see they're about to
kill or traumatize the hell of that boy obviously
she's going to use his innocent blood to torture
John uhoh
whoa oh she is sick go this is I did not see
any I any of this the boy is inest exactly so
if you let him die it's all on you this
is crazy you might want to tell the kid
the rules before we start he's not a player in
any of this oh come on John do the scary voice
you really want the boy to play without hearing
the rules I don't I think he's done a farewell
oh John I will C his throat oh he
ain't so frail right now [Music]
dude you've got 10 seconds or I hit the
Lev myself and I don't have a silly moral
cult like you trust me oh we know don't
worry I trust you fine I've gathered no
how do you get out of this bro I don't
even know you know he has to he came
back oh my god
oh Wesley Hoffman someone yeah
right where where where's Dr [Music]
Gordon whoa okay
what I have never been more engaged in a Saw movie
in my entire life right yeah this is actually
insane no
buo
Jesus what what a P4 why is that blood blooding
I don't want it I don't want it turn
it off is that all the discarded
blood I can't believe they're actually going
through with it I thought he was going to get
out of the Trap before it started they really got
the drop maybe this is the test that shows them we
need another guy on the team right yeah oh my God
this poor child that's why he says no holla cuz if
John keeps pulling no cuz it's going to go back on
the kid now oh he's going to help him out yeah oh
kiddo oh little dude
no oh my goodness stop
stop a dying man and a little
kid wow this is insane just
in case you forgot how evil they
were these two with the freaking
G let's going get the
money oh my goodness getting too much for my man
over here come on once I heard your voice over
that speaker I knew I'd be fine can't believe
they fell for the whole damn thing hul L and
sinker nope I don't like this wide angle lens but
if you were the last player who was supposed to
be on the other side of that blank with you my
man ah [Music] okay what oh [Music] baby oh what
do we got one more tape what do we have here
don't tell me John saw this coming the whole
time dude this has to be a fail safer where
Mone they you back [Music] already Jesus oh
wow yeah there that
music oh my god I've never been more happy
to hear that music on my life yeah oh my
God yeah my God there's no bullets honey
what oh my oh my oh my you are a warrior
my boy a warrior join my team what did
they know about you new passage of the
theme Parker SE okay he was in on it
he's a Handler and he's cilia too oh
I was able to find the man you asked for oh
but par you'll have to find another way oh
voice Goa yeah they left you know yeah they
wouldn't just leave the phone for no reason
love that yeah Peterson Parker Sears yes you've
each been working grift playing a role working
together continuing to play out your scam never
realizing that you have been the marks all night
[Music] [Applause] long let's go hey baby hey
you have played your last con game but not your
last game the two of you have worked together to
destroy others nope now you will work against each
other only one can survive it's going
to be Cecilia she's going to be like
bye take turns
forever I thought you forgot about [Music]
me a wa jeez man ooh W cile yeah no
oh his eyes
wow so she gets to live John
you're not going to survive in there for long you
put your head the rest of her body is going to
be here kid oh yeah exactly a go and live [Music]
buddy don't like that she kids to live
yeah is there is there an extra beat
coming here maybe oh my God wait I have an
idea but but but let's wait and see into the
sunrise saw X wow okay this she might she
may be living with some burns on her face
though so that's a plush she doesn't have all
her beauty still Kevin gr grter love you Kevin
gr well done sir that was great that was
terrific nice job Kevin yeah yeah buddy
hey man I mean I gotta give it to him like Kevin
grer has has or grutter however you say it has
directed he's probably the most Darren Bowsman
did four of them and Kevin did at least three
as director now so like he's one of the most
really Kevin yeah cuz cuz Darren Bowsman did
two through four and then spiral and then Kevin
grer did six and 3D and this really oh well this
one what about the writers though cuz this one
was like legs better in like every way this is
the writers of at least jigsaw and spiral
I want to say so this is what the happened
what gonna say you had Lee wanell uh writing
he edited it too Kevin which is and Charlie
cler's done all the scores yeah Kevin grer do
direct has edited everyone I think except the
ones he directed and except spiral um yeah this
is like leagues better than like this the oh oh
what hold it what do we got what's happening
oh is it his final game with her like oh no
yes it's that's what I was wondering you ask
where's your skull yeah oh thank you detective for
locating my fellow cancer p patient yes it was men
hello out of all the men to cheat you pick John
Kramer please don't kill me that's
the last thing that you should be
worried about now I want to play I want to play a
game whoa
oh
wow
Dam oh not bad all right loved it love it
loved it wow and you know what else I love
you guys hello there esteemed viewer of the
real rejects I Greg Alba language connoisseur
and worldly gentleman I'm here to bestow upon
you the secrets of Babel the language app that
transforms mere mortals into linguistic gods in
just three weeks why Babel you inquire my dear
friends in this age of monolingual mundanity
mundanity mity mundanity Babel is our Beacon
of Hope crafted by an army of over 150 language
experts their lessons are like linguistic caviar
Rich refined and oh so satisfying personal tail of
Triumph I once whispered sweet nothings in Spanish
or for the lame and espanol to my wife courtesy
of Babel her reaction well I'll tell you she was
utterly Bewitched Greg you silver tongue devil
no paraphrasing she exclaimed such vocabulary as
I bass in the glory of my perfect PR nunciation
this Babel isn't just about learning words it's
about embracing the art of conversation with
podcasts live classes and a veritable smorgus
sport of interactive lessons I know the words
I'm saying and their speech recognition it's
like having a personal language Butler ensuring
every syllable is impeccably crisp that breaks
yourselves for an offer of monumental proportions
here's a special limited time deal for our viewers
and listeners to get you started right now get
55% off your Babel subscription but again only
for our viewers at babel.com rejects 50 5% off
at babble.com rejects spelled b a bb.com reject
rules and restrictions May apply join me the Greg
Alin the adventure of language Mastery at Babel we
shall not just learn no nay we shall conquer the
world of communication or as they say in [Music]
Spanish we're done with this ad all righty time
to get a little bit serious so around the holiday
season we often focus on getting gifts for others
but it's it's also important to consider the gifts
that we give to ourselves personally I found that
maintaining mental health balance is a continuous
Journey cuz like I've mentioned before I've been
diagnosed with type to bipolar ADHD and PTSD and
in a lot of ways I've also grown up in the last
few years on camera with you guys and therapy
has been a crucial part of my life before the
channel even and like many of you my anxiety
and depression seems to magnify this time of year
still don't quite understand the winter Blues but
it does however therapy does help me navigate the
ups and downs and stay grounded for the most part
and while I have my own approach to therapy I
understand everyone's path is unique and that's
why we proud to be sponsored by betterhelp this
week it's an online platform that makes therapy
accessible and tailor to your needs and I know
a few people who have discovered therapy via
betterhelp and it has been transformative you
start with a questionnaire that helps match
you with a licensed therapist and the best part
and an important part you can switch therapist
anytime ensuring the right fit for you better
help is all about convenience and flexibility
it fits into your schedule and it's all online so
whether you're looking to start therapy for the
first time or continue your journey better help
can be a great option so in the season of giving
remember to give yourself what you need to with
better help take that step towards your better
self so you can visit betterhelp.com rejects for
10% off your first month that's betterhelp.com
rejects take care and stay healthy reject Nation
happy holidays and now I just have to say that saw
10 is so good oh my God you guys I'm ready to just
be like 10 out of 10 this one this is like X Out
of X this is yes you did it you did it you did it
like thank you I was in it from like the beginning
to the very end and now there's like times where
I wasn't saying anything cuz I just did I was so
pulled in and I was so engulfed I love the way
they played like cinematic this is also I feel
like the most cinematically shot even though
which is surprising to me that you're seeing
Kevin he directed the other ones I really liked
how they played with the lighting especially in
regards to John they made him like he was always
backlit a little bit like he was Angelic in this
and I love how to me John is the person that I'm
like no he's the best person in this even though
he's like John Kramer who's done all these weird
games with this movie really they did like a joker
thing where you're like show his life and now
show how he got here and I think I really was
thrown into Jon's moral code the most in this one
even though they've placed it in other movies saw
X brought it to the Forefront and man oh man you
did a great job hundo P absolutely agree you guys
get to it yeah man I feel like they they really
changed the formula of this Saw movie and like
granted all of them have had their own variations
of the story but they started to get a little bit
repetitive as far as like the motifs of which they
would use but this one was drastically different
from all the other ones with the fact that he was
like the front and center and like I was surprised
because we've never never had him as like the up
in front protagonist before but to see that and
you get you to root for him was incredible the
way it was shot was incredible the traps were
incredible seeing his moral code in full force in
the in the sense that you know we really get to be
in his shoes because these people have personally
wronged him which was something like we've never
really seen before and from this kind of franchise
especially from this kind of franchise and Amanda
was was great and like the the fact that even
though they haven't played the characters to
this extent in close to what like 15 or so years
something around there it's almost it's going on
20 years now almost 20 years 2004 was saw one yeah
was saw one but the fact that there's able to just
slip back right into them I know JN has like
been something continuous with like flashbacks
or short appearances but the fact that he was like
the front and center and also Amanda being there
with and they're they were able to stay true
to who those characters were m not from like
a revisionist standpoint but like authentically
where we met them in that place and yeah man
everything was just so gripping like there was
kind of how Tera was saying I was locked in the
whole time my jaw was like you'll watch it back
my jaw was dropped for like I damn near like 30
seconds like at some point cuz I was just like so
enthralled in what was going to happen and even
though we know that they're going to live cuz
this is obviously an in between cool the stakes
in which and how they played it was just so stable
and so enthralling I was just I was blown away and
I think this movie I'm not I'm not sure if it's
um oh something I am sure of is the fact that it's
damn it's in the top three easily if not if not
the best one but something I wasn't sure of going
in was how it was going to keep us engaged in that
and I feel like rooting it in his his experience
was the best way to go about that and yeah it
was it was incredible it was incredible and
and one last thing I'll say is that because we've
watched 10 of these it makes this one so much more
rewarding because we've seen this journey from its
Inception in one through 10 and I think maybe it
could stand on its own still enjoy it but I think
it's that much more enriching because we've gone
through John and Amanda and Hoffman and getting
to this point just French Kiss absolutely kiss
AB both both kinds of kiss both kind of kisses
it makes me curious because I think this one has
the best opportunity to stand on its own um along
with the first one I think those two have the most
Standalone ability barring like Spiral because
that's clearly kind of in a pocket side Universe
um and but the the cool thing is while I'm sure
you could do a rewatch with this in the middle I
think as much as they have said like the producers
kind of realize like oh maybe killing a off was a
mistake um and and part of wonders if you could
have this movie as exactly as it is make the
impact that it makes without all the time that we
have spent the fact that we miss this guy like we
already have enough to stand on in terms of Tobin
Bell is a great actor he clearly cares about this
role he's well documented as having you know given
a lot of his own creativity to it and so 10 year
or or not 10 years 20 almost 20 years of Saw and
the 10th installment it almost feels like a very
appropriate full circle to do something like this
and to have a movie that yeah hands over the focus
hands over the narrative to the guy it it almost
it's kind of reminded me of like the freshness
that like a saw two hat where it's like oh damn we
know who this guy is and now we're going to spend
time with him for most of the movie and here I I
love the compliment of the first movie he's not
talking to anybody but he's running the game he's
on the floor in the room and in this one he's in
the room giving the a dress like literally just
watching and orchestrating and kind of doing it
on the fly a little bit in a way that felt very
palpable and tangible and I think it fits nicely
between these earlier installments I believe it is
supposed to be between you know at least one and
two and uh and yeah the way it's like they didn't
even H I wasn't even thinking about daging or
anything like clearly they look a bit older than
they do in Saw 2 and I didn't care at all because
the emotional quality and the attention to detail
on the characters their relationship back and
forth was really nicely done Hoffman makes for a
perfect little Easter egg because obviously might
have some involvement here um and so yeah this was
able to do so many different things that are like
that you would want out of a commemorative sequel
of sorts like but it has fan service without ever
feeling like it's trying to Pander fan service you
know and uh and yeah having this real kind of uh
uh deliberate pace and allowing you to be with
John on his journey really experience you know
what his life is like living with his cancer and
the other people around and the solidarity they
show between them him and the other Survivor
or the other people who are you know trying
to become survivors basically and then you know
it's like Amanda and Gabriella and all that stuff
there's so many like great little attentions
to character in detail and then you know you
bring in all the other trappings of you know the
stylistic flourishes and the ghost trails and the
freakouts and the traps and even if this doesn't
have the most outlandish or the most complicated
traps necessarily I thought the way that they
showed Jon's eye for it like this is the best use
of a fake out like imagination trap because the
eyeball vacuum is probably the most recognizable
thing from this movie each movie has like a trap
you might refer to I feel like the eyeball is the
is like the most iconic that this movie has in
terms of just like a striking visual with the
tubes and all that and using all the marketing too
yeah totally and so having that be a beat where it
doesn't actually happen to the guy but you you see
what Jon's motivation is in watching him and also
how he's starting to formulate what the Trap might
be because he's noticing the person in traction on
the bed and then that informs the finger snaps and
it's just like little things like that that makes
all the sense that we couldn't really do before
when we're doing like yeah each one of these like
police procedural and we're always going you
know crazy sort of semi melodrama semi like
super convoluted twists and I love all that and
I thought that this managed to do so much classic
saw while also structuring out a movie that felt
different and felt very conscientious of like
yeah maybe a variable mighten maybe this somebody
might find you out here in a place where you don't
have as much control as you would just back home
conducting something like this and uh and yeah
like the group of them the contrast of like she's
clearly guiding this whole procedure for the grift
and then she's got to freaking guide them all
through these traps and and I I you know I I think
I'm curious to hear how you guys left off at least
with the main antagonist you know she doesn't die
she doesn't get subject to the worst trap but I
still feel pretty Satisfied by the end that this
person has been appropriately sort of torn down
and scarred by her own horrific choices oh yeah I
mean she's got burns on her face she doesn't have
any of the money and I'm sure the rest of her body
in there is probably messed up oh yeah and I'm I'm
glad that she has to walk around like that like
I'm like yeah go walk around because now it's like
the scars show your evil cuz I hope people have to
go hey what real quick what happened to the what
happened to you to you and then maybe she has to
go well I'm a raging SE uh and that's why but
uh yeah how did you feel about her getting you
feel good but like it's like I feel he he does
like that she's still alive I knew died yeah I
like get her outsides match her insides but she
was like the worst like this is the first time
because Grant we've watched a lot of Saw movies at
this point we've seen a lot of of douchebags and
and and a-holes in this movie but by far she's the
worst out of all of them hatable the most hatable
and I was like wow I feel like this is the first
time we've gotten like a straight up villain to
oppose jigsaw in a in a sense not necessarily
matching wits but like someone who makes this
guy who does horrible things Justified because she
is so equally or more than him just evil just evil
just because cuz money and yeah man I granted I
liked the movie a lot I that's the only thing it
doesn't change my rating at all but I was like oh
I wish she would have gotten her kupets because
she sucked she does I also feel like all of the
casting in this great job Nancy I mean I'm like
always trying to hit up Nancy be like yo girl
call me in for your stuff but I love this all
put me in put me in whatever n does great great
stuff shout out to you uh but everyone in this
was really really grounded I've not seen that and
a lot of the saws there's certain times you have
seen us laugh out loud at the way that the actors
have said lines and we don't do that cuz you guys
love that detective and saw 3D he he like oh my
God we were mad we were actually we laughed out
loud we were so angry about it like how is this
supposed to be taken seriously and that did not
happen here obviously at all which is so great but
I also feel like the writers uh when's the last
time what number did we see Hoffman in the last
time we saw Hoffman he in seven last time he's
in seven so we've seen eight eight and nine was
the we didn't like eight right I was madw eight
was jigsaw then nine technically spiral with rock
I was mad both times I think so the writers I feel
like learn the lessons uh there slightly because
this had a really great ending and I know uh Jos
stolberg name has popped up I think on seven and
eight I follow him on the Twitter and the grams
he's a cool guy you guys um should too he's great
but um this one really brought it all together and
I'm really glad that they were like let's choose
Hoffman and Amanda and not that weird guy that we
put in eight to just that was he was he was here
the whole time you guys know that I was mad about
it for a week um thank you for tossing that out
the window yeah and and just bringing back these
characters that we really like and bringing this
story to life that you knew like this sells this
is one of the best saws so con congrats they
didn't try to over complicate it either they
brought it back to basics well keeping it just
uh complicated or just um intricate enough to be
like the satisfying experience because like that's
finale we were on the edge of our seats and I was
like I don't know how I was going to get out of
this and then the fact that there was this twist
cuz I remember saying that earlier in the movie
like I don't know how there's going to be a Twist
in this movie and sure enough it was that exactly
there was and it was it was it was good yeah it's
like it's well proportioned for the most part
because they would have some kind of contingency
it makes sense that they would do that it makes
sense that they might you know knowing that they
have a variable to work with with this guy yeah
that they might try and proof it and I guess my
only question I'm left with is that if this woman
is Left Alive and she knows who he is uh I I would
have to imagine that in my own head Cannon maybe
Hoffman just comes and finishes it something or
different rules yeah you know because because I
I was almost expecting and I love that they did
the post credits tag with the guy and that was a
great I think you one of you guys yeah was like
wait a minute but he had the scar what's going
on with that and I love that they didn't forget
about that and part of me was expecting like oh if
there's a sting maybe it'll be her re-up into some
kind of gruesome trap but I think what I think
it's a neat choice and I'm going to chew on it
for a while but partly because it it shows Jon's
adherence to his own philosophy yeah so it's like
she played the game by the rules despite all this
you know despite you know usurping the game and
mocking it and being the worst in the process and
yet still uh even though we are probably all right
there with Amanda being like she deserves nothing
and she only proves that further and further you
know they get to walk off as you know a momentary
little family in a way that you know it's bright
there's Angelic light but it didn't feel too
cheesy and I feel like they they kept the cheese
just the right amount in this and for the most
part yeah this as a reinvention goes I think is
really lovely because it's not about let's Beef
It Up and let's make it more sleek and Mak make
it crazier it's no let's take our time and make
the most like cinematic film that we have made
since the first movie yeah cu the first movie
has this charm of like yeah it's it's clearly
a grungy lowbudget movie but it's got cinematic
aspirations on its mind not to say the others
aren't cinematic but there's a different popcorn
quality that comes in whereas this yeah definitely
feels like in some ways tonally this is probably
like the best made and conceived and executed in
a lot of ways I mean you can't do this probably
without the first one and I think doing this is
number 10 and having the push pull of like John's
gone we've got him in flashbacks it's good to have
him but it's problematic that he's dead I think
that helps this movie really kind of earn all of
its aspirations and the things that it attempts
to do so yeah like as both a fan of Saw who will
take you know a schlock saw happily love that side
of the franchise I also love you know Cinema and I
love that they caringly because this has also been
something of a family Endeavor you know it's like
even though there are 10 of these there's been you
know you've had the same few writers for stretches
you've had the same handful of people guiding
the direction for stretches and you have like
the same composer throughout the same editor
throughout and it's able to grow but I think
really organically maintain its core elements
and as a compared to any other horror franchise
and often they'll have you know a shepherd of
some kind but this feels weirdly like the most
sort of organically earnestly kind of Spun and
guided by just this little group of people who
make movies cuz you watch the credits and you just
see so many like names and you know and hats off
to Kevin grard man like he's he's been here since
the first one and uh and I love that I mean I I'm
a I'm a Darren Bowsman fan for various reasons and
I like his saw joints but I feel like James Juan
and Kevin grard are probably like the best stamps
and then you have Darren Bowman who helped really
flesh out what this franchise would become and
brought a lot of cool stylistic flourishes too
but it's yeah it's just been cool to see both on
screen what they've done over time and especially
with this and the creatives behind it and how
that's all kind of you know become this little
group this this band of you know game makers the
saw hor people you guys did a great job you made
a cinematic thing with lots of dope games and
we loved it you had the horror aspect it wasn't
over the top we didn't need it we want to sit
with story like we did in the first and the
second one we finally got that we've been yelling
about it for weeks so yay I love this movie like
I really thank you thank you thank you this has
a this has a not only like a fresh score but it
has like a legit like it's like 809 like close
to 90 or something or at least when it came out
like it was a lot of reviews and a like solidly
fresh percentage which like blew my mind I never
thought I'd say this but this has I've seen a lot
of movies this year and this has a solid chance of
making my top 10 I know I predicted that on the
live stream this afternoon I was like I had seen
it yet but I think saw will make my list yeah man
like thank you guys for making this film we love
you so much don't forget to leave a like leave
a comment tell us how cool we are tell us how
much you also love this movie we are at the end
of our journey right now but maybe they'll make
an 11th and we'll be back oh there'll be more as
long as to and Bell's alive make these and and
find a way to keep the heart this is a Saw movie
with the heart like how crazy is that like make
make that we love you guys so much make sure you
buy a t-shirt reject naations shop.com um also I
forgot to say this uh if you're listening on
Apple or Spotify as a podcast make sure you
rate this episode we love it we need get those
ratings up you know what I mean five stars baby
join patreon if you haven't already we love you
so much and we will see you on the next one bye
bye